welcome back to the show everyone
whether you're a kid who's 12 years old
or younger or an adult older than 19
you're gonna love this episode
if you're a teenager it may already be
too late you think you've got what it
takes not rushmore may have four
presidents but it's only got room for
three baddie slashers
freddy krueger jason voorhees and
michael myers
or as i'd call them if i wrote for the
local newspaper the enigma of elm street
versus the killer of camp crystal lake
versus the hatton field halloween hunk
ah
i missed that improv's tough everyone
it's the debate you and your friends
have had since the dawn of time
or at least 1984 who's the best horror
movie bad guy
today we're going to settle just that by
tossing into the vitamix your favorite
dream master
the iconic undead goalie and the world's
meanest
trick-or-treater it's about to be the
most violent goriest
bloodiest threesome you've ever seen
welcome to my nightmare
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
round three cultural relevance and then
if i'm still alive we'll do a wild card
round to settle the score
two of these fellas fought in a movie
once and it was a good battle only
problem was it appeared to end in a draw
but now we're adding michael myers to
the vip list and only one of these three
stalking stalwarts of cinema
will get bragging rights in hell where i
believe jason has a summer home
let's get it on
round one box office the year was 1978.
jimmy carter was president the
pittsburgh steelers were etching their
name into the record books
and parents were concerned about their
kids listening to that darn van
halen but by the time october rolled
around 1978 became about one thing
this new halloween movie you had to see
and keep your eyes open the whole time
to believe
grossing 188 million dollars on a
shoestring
budget that adjusted barely over 1
million dollars in today's world
halloween was celebrated as a horror
film rebirth and it would spawn
10 sequels reboots that all told have
grossed 851 million bucks
for a 77 million dollar per film average
those numbers are greatly enhanced by
the most recent entry into the legendary
franchise
2018's cleverly titled halloween
which would total 165 million dollars in
total domestic receipts and perhaps it
was the looming presence of michael
myers that inspired jason and freddie to
make their own movies
j-dogs can would be up next beginning
with 1980s
friday the 13th kill our mommy yes i
know it was jason's mommy who was doing
the stabbing during the first one but
she was doing it for her
boy so even though we don't see the
iconic jason trying out for the local
rec league hockey team look until the
third film
i'm giving him credit for the entire
franchise it's what his mom would have
wanted
and to be frank i don't feel like dying
over it
[Music]
friday the 13th flicks have racked up
862 million
total bucks over the course of 12 movies
making for a golf clappable
72 million dollars per film average
strictly in terms of box office the gold
standard is still the original
sporting a canon record 138 million
dollar resume line
and then there were two and for most
teens that would be plenty
but then 1984 happened and not even your
worst orwellian nightmare could compete
with the shut-eye action going down
on elm street freddy krueger a former
janitorial enthusiast with a limited
wardrobe budget
debuted on the big screen with a 68
million dollar total domestic haul
unlike his colleagues fred wouldn't see
his highest solo box office
until his fourth movie subtitled the
dream master
grossing 113 million bucks krueger and
his zany one-liners have starred in a
total of nine movies
raking in a combined bushel of 739
million dollars
for an average of 82 million per flick
no pain
all three fellas came out of the box
office gates swinging for a very
competitive round one
if you look at the top 12 of their
combined best money making movies
each psychopath has four movies on the
list
but it's halloween claiming the top two
spots were the 1978
and 2018 films respectively and while
friday the 13th has the highest total
gross
and nightmare number street boasts the
highest per film average halloween
is a close second in both categories and
we have to point out that mikey
doesn't have the advantage of a
successful crossover movie freddie
versus jason
did happen and made 128 million dollars
on its way to disappointing me
by not declaring a true winner [ __ ] what
you think
sealing the deal for me is the return on
investment all three franchises burst
onto the scene with a remarkable ability
to spin straw
into gold freddy's rookie flick cost
just 1.8 million dollars at the time
while jason's mom's opening budget was
even lower
at 550 000 but it was michael
alligator arms when the check arrives
myers
who got his movie made for just 325 000
dollars at the time
and it was probably that initial success
that made film executives say
hey can can we do that in a camp or or
over on that boulevard named after a
tree
every town has an elm street
even though he kills people without
remorse michael makes tons of money for
his crew
so he gets the win in round number one
he
can't kill the boogeyman round two
tomato meter slash
audience score before i ask the usual
question of
sure you made money but were the movies
any good let's go ahead and free the
caps from their environmental friendly
reusable bag
each of these gentlemen have made some
real stinkers you think a dismembered
body smells bad
wait until you get a whiff of how rotten
some of these movies are on the tomato
meter
you really shouldn't fall asleep in
class
all three guys have multiple movies that
are 15
or below it's jason taking the brunt of
it with a record low 8
for that time he took manhattan taking
an unwanted silver medal is millennial
of note
paul rudd in halloween the curse of
michael myers
earning just nine percent sorry and
maybe the most disappointing of all
would be the 2010 remake of nightmare
and elm street which scored 15 percent
that's supposed to course correct to get
the franchise back on the right path
huh nope oh no robert england
look i love you jackie you are great and
bad news bears but there's only one
freddy
and his name is robbie it's a boy
[Music]
but so what if they've had some missteps
in their time there's some good in there
too right
yes in fact there's a ton of it the
tomato meter top 10
features two movies from jason including
his only fresh flick his mom's friday
the 13th at 64 percent
and three halloween movies headlined by
the overall clubhouse leader
and granddaddy of them all 1978's
original
with 96 what's the boogie man
as a matter of fact it was but it's
freddy who has
five movies in the top ten hey that's
one for each razor blade
topping out with his original 1984
introduction at 94 percent and it's
worth noting that while the 2010
nightmare on elm street tanked with
critics
the 1994 meta tour de force wes craven's
new nightmare
is currently at 80 percent
[Music]
but before i give the round to fred
let's take a gander at that audience
score
nightmare and halloween each sport three
movies that made it fresh with audiences
meanwhile friday the 13th only has its
original bragging about being fresh
barely at 60 percent
[Applause]
and for overall audience score average
it's once again between the dream dude
and the holiday guy
freddie's average is 50.1 percent
michael's is 50.3 percent
you see kids voting does matter
and so does a tomato meter freddie
dominates average score over there
winning easily with 50.4 percent over
his closest competition michael myers at
37
so sir lord krueger round two is yours
and i'm sure you'd like to celebrate
with one of your classic comedic barbs
have at it no i'm playing with power
round three cultural relevance hey wanna
guess the real reason why we're doing
this vid
because people still care they love
these three awful
human beings and even decades after
their debuts
no one in the horror game has come close
to the cultural relevance of the big
three
ghostface good effort darth maul looking
guy from insidious
cool weird dude from sinister update
your home movie technology
since mikey came along first and decided
to base his murderous rampages around a
popular holiday
it's safe to say he's made it into the
hall of killer fame
it was already impressive that halloween
h2o saw a dramatic uptick in box office
from previous entries in the franchise
and then to do it even more successfully
20 years later we still crave michael
myers
if you need more evidence think of the
iconic slasher films before 1978
peeping tom black christmas not exactly
household names
the only reason we'd mention psycho is
because of that legendary shower scene
and remember who is bleeding chocolate
syrup janet lee
aka jamie lee curtis's mom life is just
one big nascar track kids
we've all had bad things happen to us
the trick is to concentrate on today
we might not have mr myers competition
today if not for his inaugural movie
and that flick also popularized the use
of panaglite which is how john carpenter
managed to get those super eerie
first-person glimpses from michael's
perspective
audiences were frightened film students
were like oh
it looks so smooth but maybe carpenter's
best contribution to the legacy of the
shape
is the musical score that he composed
himself you know it instantly and it may
be second only to jaws
as far as themes that can instantly
scare the hell out of you
do i smell a crossover could a shark
pull off wearing that halloween mask
speaking of memorable themes how about a
little kid belting out
one two freddy's coming for you
[Music]
ominous lyrics plus singing children
that's a coca-cola level formula that
equals pure creepiness
the only thing to fear is fear
himself freddy krueger also has his
staple autumnal wear
the sweater the filthy hat the dockers
the glove
sure it may not be quite as strong as
adamantium but wolverine can only use
his claws when he's awake
or having a really intense dream like
what happens
constantly to those teens on elm street
what separates fred from the pack is his
speaking ability yeah
he can talk as a matter of fact he won't
shut up wanna suck
face i don't believe his fairy tales
his one-liners are part and parcel for
any good entry into the nightmare in elm
street canon
sure they occasionally get ridiculous
but it's hard to accuse him of dad jokes
when you're running for your life
plus it gives him a backup career as a
comic for tickets head to uncle
freddyslayz.net
references by everyone from the fresh
prince and dj
jazzy jeff to nicki minaj have kept
freddy krueger alive and well in the
cultural zeitgeist
plus he had doc into his soundtrack for
the dream warriors which proves that the
music in hell
kicks way more ass so now it looks like
only jason voorhees is standing in the
way of another freddy round
i'll let jason have some fun
you hear that the dude doesn't even need
a proper theme song he can just chill us
by cueing up that weird breathing track
on pro tools
and while jason certainly won't be
competing against michael phelps for
swimming records anytime soon
his contribution to athletics is
undeniable that
hockey mask it already looked neat but
now that a serial killer from beyond the
grave has donned one
it's the go-to mask for anyone needing a
last-second costume party idea
jason has made the rounds including
winning an mtv lifetime achievement
award
appearing on the arsenio hall show and
blessing us with some of our first
degrees of kevin bacon
but it's not just the fame of jason or
his banned nike commercial that makes
him an icon
it's the day he represents so
the curse of friday the 13th actually
finds its origins well before 1980
it dates back to early christian
mythology friday was the day of the last
supper and who was the last apostle to
show up at applebee's
yep it was judas that judas
he was the 13th guest on that friday
but all the jesus plus ones in the world
can't compete with what that day
represents now
when a friday the 13th hits weird things
happen to people
some folks stay indoors call in sick to
work shut the blinds
others celebrate it with a party that
even the earliest of all hallow z
participants would appreciate and why is
all that
because of jason voorhees had it not
been for his consistent pole position
lodged in the forefront of our brains
every time we go camping
watch an nhl game and especially wake up
on certain fridays
no one would bat an eye at the 13th of
the month but thanks to jason
with a hockey assist from his mom pam
friday the 13th and its favorite mascot
serve as a looming reminder to tread
lightly jason gets to win in round three
and once you know it we're all tied up
going into
let's see if you're a hockey fan we've
already had three periods so
overtime and yes freddy this one's for
you
it's sudden death sticks and stones may
break my bones
but nothing will ever kill me
and now it's time for the wild card
round iconic moments
okay because this is a safe space where
we can be honest with one another
this round is all about kills i didn't
want to shout that from the rooftop at
the beginning of the episode
but now that you've stuck with me this
long who's the best at fictional
murdering
step right up voorhees family like any
great mother mrs jason did her son a
huge
solid by showing him the ropes
unfortunately these ropes were actually
machetes and chainsaws you know maybe
she wasn't that good of a mom
but oh boy was her son ever good at
killing
jason punched the dude's head clean off
when he took manhattan
he just popped that sucker out like it
was t-ball and in friday the 13th part
four
check out this sick corkscrew maneuver
that jason performs on none other
than mr george mcfly crispin glover hey
you
get your damn hands off him
but my favorite jason moment is when he
straight up folds a poor sucker in half
like he's breaking down boxes to be a
good recycler this kill happens in the
film where freddy and jason square off
they weren't just battling over turf it
was a war to see who is the best baddie
of all time
so now the undead demon from elm street
has the floor
it's time to put this bad dog to sleep
i love freddy because so many of his
kills are on brand the guy haunts you in
your dreams
so naturally he loves a good bedroom
bloodbath johnny depp gets sucked into
his own bed
but fred also got in on the late 80s
waterbed craze
as evidence in the dream master
but the best krueger kills go down to
nightmare and elm street 3 the dream
warriors
a group of troubled teens many
struggling with addiction now have to
wrestle with burn
bastard son too and it didn't go well
poor tina finally gets to be on
television but not in the way she hoped
and this fellow became a literal meat
puppet years before that band hit it big
with backwater swirl
but more so than any one kill it's the
spirit of the sick demented fun that
freddie brings to each tragedy that
keeps us coming back for more
as opposed to say michael myers who
rather than sick pleasure
seems to be motivated by a constantly
running set of batteries hell bent on
halloween mayhem
from poor bob in the first halloween can
we check how many
fellas named bob actually survive horror
movies i'm betting not a lot
maybe go by robert from now on and then
as if being named karen wasn't already
tough
look at what happens to this one in
halloween too
rob zombie's halloween film saw the
gruesome end of our beloved octavius
spencer's character
as well as the seemingly indestructible
machete himself
danny trejo doesn't matter who you are
michael myers is there to kill you quick
and payment and while both he and jason
may not be the most
personable of movie villains they got
their job done with ruthless efficiency
and permanently altered our perception
of halloween and friday the 13th
but it's freddy krueger who not only
used his glove his imagination and his
ability to infiltrate dreams to win our
hearts
it was his mouth ever played in the cat
perhaps he spent a little too much time
on the wisecracks in a few of the films
but he's the consummate entertainer he
knows he's there to kill
teens as a means of revenge for their
parents burning him alive years ago
but freddie is also well aware there's
an audience of millions witnessing the
carnage
as much as he doesn't care about the
lives of victims he does care about
giving us
the most bang for our buck the jokes the
creativity
the passion whether he's in some random
bedroom or
on his home court basement boiler room
freddy krueger is the horror movie
villain that gives us his all
every time he sets foot in our dreams
for that he wins this round and thus
the match
freddie michael jason you're all winners
in my book and i'm not just saying that
because i prefer to not be hacked to
pieces
you are the champions but it's been no
bet of roses for the legions of kills
you've committed for both personal
reasons and our entertainment value
for funsies you want to know which of
the big three is killed the most
it's jason making his mama proud the big
goalie is hovering at around 157 kills
edging out michael myers total of 140.
freddy is bringing up the rear at barely
40 kills
but today's match was about quality over
quantity
jason might win if all three were tossed
into a pit and had to duke it out
all other things being equal i'd give
the tiebreaker to a mom
but not the mom you think let's shout
out amanda krueger
freddy's mom she pops up in dream
warriors as this ominous looking
nun and i think she's trying to help
nancy in the gang but her mere presence
scares the hell out of me maybe it's the
fact that she gave birth to a child
murderer
or that she's a ghost or that she's
wearing the all-white nun look the away
uniform for any sister of mercy
mandy gave us the best horror movie
villain there is the hat
the sweater the guy who's probably
playing the jacksonville comedy zone
this weekend
now coming to the stage grab your
crucifix it's freddy krueger
but that's just one guy's opinion and i
don't live on elm street have never been
camping
and haven't trick-or-treated in at least
11 months so now
it's your turn vote in the comments
section for who you think is the best of
the bad
freddie jason or the og michael
thanks for watching everyone and
remember don't go into any wooded areas
avoid anyone named strode on halloween
and nap with a buddy yeah good luck with
the sleep thing
you